bonsoir ça va salut elle est là
bonsoir
[Musique]
ça va
c'est une boîte de fille
[Musique]
mais peu
c'est quel genre de garçon qui sont
admis ici
en général
[Musique]
donc je peux revenir ouais super moi je
voudrais bien un coup là
[Musique]
il y a pas de de jeunes ou tout le monde
se mélange et comme c'est une boîte
conviviale tout le monde s'apprécie tout
le monde sait voilà maintenant
absolument
c'est à nouveau lieu
qu'on accepte d'en parler ou ça a
toujours été comme ça où il y a une mode
je pense que c'est une mode
exclusivement une mode il y a besoin
d'être reconnu il y a besoin de plein de
choses et bon les filles les filles
elles existent elles vivent entre elles
les mecs c'est pareil et puis pourquoi
cacher cette vérité puisqu'elle est là
en ce moment
peut-être parce que les mecs ils
assurent pas ah bon je sais pas
fait un mec oh moi ça fait 15 20 ans
c'est du rapide tu sais le système de
drague maintenant dans les boîtes c'est
pas je t'invite au restaurant c'est bon
tu me plais allez hop en rentrant
ensemble c'est fini encore
celles qui ont passé 40 ans tu vois
comme moi par exemple j'ai besoin de ça
quelqu'un qui me dit tout de suite
mais quelqu'un qui me qui me drague je
dis oui bien sûr
avec les mecs alors parce que qu'est-ce
qui m'a fait arrêter les mecs c'est très
simple c'est que j'ai rencontré les
filles en fait j'ai rencontré une femme
et puis ça a été dix fois mieux avec une
femme
j'ai trouvé que la femme était beaucoup
plus tendre était beaucoup plus
totalement c'est pour ça que j'ai viré
de ce côté-là
faut faire des flics
des trucs comme ça
dépend de la demande si les filles
même avec une fille tu as besoin
[Musique]
j'ai commencé comme ça le hasard Marie
Dorcel m'a choisi et voilà mais comment
était choisi
un peu sur M6
premier jour je l'avais fait de la
figuration il m'a pas mis directement
dans le hit pour que je vois comment ça
se passe voilà exactement et après
deuxième jour encore la figuration et
avec un peu plus de repos et le
troisième chose c'est là que j'ai
commencé à faire mes scènes
avec Christophe
très gentil agréable mettez en confiance
il m'a mis à l'aise et tout aucun
problème vraiment très très bien
[Musique]
difficile surtout que quand tu l'as
jamais fait c'est impressionnant sinon
ça se passe bien quand même mais bon
faut se raconter quelque chose dans la
tête et après le cadre j'ai dit je
m'imagine des choses dans la tête pour
me faire un peu mouiller les trucs comme
ça voilà parce que quand ça dure très
longtemps c'est quand même pénible mais
sinon
à être bien à l'image donc je pense dans
ma tête un petit fantasme des trucs
comme ça
comme j'ai mouillé un peu il y a pas de
problème
toutes les choses moches vulgaire j'aime
pas ça
je reste toute simple j'aime
bien
c'est différent que dans la vie privée
c'est plus intime tu as plus envie de le
faire que sur un ton âge tu le fais
parce que c'est ton travail
vie privée c'est autre chose c'est comme
toi tu l'aimeras ta femme et c'est pas
du tout comme un tournage c'est
différent
[Musique]
non je fais ce que j'ai envie et si j'ai
pas envie je dis non
par exemple la double peinée
d'ailleurs parce que les gens oui il y a
double pénétration
vaginale Léana
donc toi tu faisais la double peinée
anal et vaginale c'est pas un problème
dans ma vie préférée
mais la double peine
dans la vigne au cinéma
dès qu'on parle de pénétration à mon
avis c'est la choper
mais dis-moi donc la double planète
n'est pas d'accord
tu as proposé Dorcel tu as dit non pour
l'instant
je me sentirais bien pour le faire je
ferai mais sinon je fais pas partie
plein de choses non
c'est trop moche
[Musique]
vulgarité je n'aime pas
naturel pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez
un pouce bleu